on en vient maintenant aux élections
sénatoriales avec un record de
candidatures 1996 parmi elles 9 109
femmes c'est aussi un record mais
également de nombreux battu aux
législatives où d'anciens ministres à
samia de chiens parmi les recalés de
l'assemblée nationale beaucoup retentent
leur chance au sénat c'est ce qu'on
appelle le recyclage des candidats et
d'après un décompte du journal le monde
la palme revient au front national 40 %
des candidats frontistes ont déjà tenté
leur chance au palais bourbon en juin
dernier
parmi eux vallerand de saint-just pour
lui le parti n'aurait pas d'autre choix
les perdants au législatif sont souvent
les têtes d'affichés du fn dans leur
département et donc les mieux placés
pour se lancer dans les sénatoriales
l'institution du sénat et elle est le
mode d'élection et elle s'est quand même
très archaïque et très ringard un bon
que on est un peu obligé de mettre sur
les listes soient comme tête de liste
soit dans une autre position
les personnalités du parti politique les
plus connus dans département parce qu'il
faut que ces grands électeurs
les maires les conseillers municipaux
les conseillers départementaux tout ça
ils sont un peu dans le même monde
il faut que je reconnaisse cola le front
national est loin d'être le seul à
recycler ses candidats d'une assemblée à
l'autre à droite par exemple jacques
myard dans les yvelines ou encore marc
philippe daubresse dans le nord ont tout
deux échoué à entrer à l'assemblée
nationale cette année avant de briguer
un poste de sénateur à gauche laurent
baumel re tente lui aussi sa chance en
indre et loire après son échec aux
dernières législatives
en tout sur près de 2000 prétendants aux
sénatoriales cette année 280 sont des
candidats battus aux dernières
législatives